I want to like we're number that really
missed some to me I was like what number
can really stick with me and me
something to me and that was stood over
because of my dad
[Music]
I never really got to grow up with him
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I grew up and she ATO
it was exciting because we already had
two girls we didn't want so it was
really excited his dad literally was
running around saying it's a boy humble
father figure it love family like that I
really remember one memory like very
clear it's funny we was having like a
barbecue at a whole bunch of family
members was over and we was just having
fun when he chose and I don't know who
told him to do this but we had a big old
truck and he decided to drive it in the
mud and just do circles and just be
goofy and the guys stuck the truck got
stuck and I had to go get the other
track to get it out he was outgoing guy
and I miss him
[Music]
Shafi otto it's not beautiful like
downtown and in a city it's rough you
know you could walk up the street random
things that happen sometimes to people
that don't have nothing to do with the
street gangs to drugs it's like more of
like gangs and violence down there
basically too bad for us yellow schools
getting locked down because somebody's
shooting in the area things like that
it's scary for me to have a child you
know over in this area
it was tough like you always had to look
out for yourself just walking down the
street and your parents always worried
about you it was mostly sports
basketball with his dad he had my son in
front of the house shooting baskets you
know telling him how to hold the ball
dribble it at four so I think probably
that Kevin remembers that and just never
put the ball down I got a phone call
went to where he was at and
they just basically said that he's still
in there
[Music]
I was like what do you mean
and then they finally told me that he's
deceased so it was real hard for me to
have to go and tell my three kids that
their dad's not coming home the oldest
ones kind of knew what happened Kevin he
didn't really know I'd even let him go
to the funeral I want him to remember
his dad the way he remembered his dad
I don't like remember much but like I
know he was he was shot multiple times
and
it wasn't it I was basically a taint of
that it's still rough talking about it
cuz to be honest I haven't really talked
about that since I haven't I haven't let
it out I don't want to remember it I
guess so
she knew it was gonna be tough mentally
for me as a kid without a father growing
up
I believe the basketball it helps him
process he knows this is what his father
did and this is what he's gonna do to
remember his father my mom was really
that father figure I mean that's why I
look to her for like a lot of things
that I should know probably by now but I
still do even if I'm sure about it I
still have to ask her because she was
like everything to me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
of course I'm nervous you know it'sit's
a big step in my life having an
opportunity like I always dreamed about
it being an MBA which you want to be a
NBA player since I was five
what's your plan be out all got one so
[Music]
I'm seeing it in front of my face I'm
nervous but I'm like damn I'm ready we
got it
I'm sure today a lot of people call me
Kevin Porter and I get like offended
because I'm a junior like basically a
2.0 of my father he's an image of his
dad and it's just it makes me smile just
hearing her say those words
means I got two legacies to fulfill and
like I want to create my own but bring
his with me this time hey it's Master
here with Br please subscribe to check
out some more great video content